on this link you will find
a number of relevant resources
so you can log in first
um please let me know once you're here
essentially to log in
you go to the login tab and you will see
here that you can create an account
with your email and password or with one
of the social media
networks if you have a profile there so
please let me know how many of you have
already created an account
you can put number one in the chat box
if you have already created an account
all right thank you emmanuel okay
great thank you everyone
okay if you have already created an
account
you should be able to go to your profile
so on this profile there are several
important things to remember
on this profile you will see your
picture
obviously we want to have a name and a
face so that we can
connect with you there are some social
media
accounts that you can connect to your
profile so we would love to stay in
touch on
linkedin on facebook on instagram
know about your research work and
twitter
so please update some of this
information that you're comfortable
sharing you can also put a short
blurb about yourself so give us a sense
of who you are are you a student are you
a faculty member
maybe you're already a trainer and an
expert so we would love to get to know
you
and then what you will start seeing is
as we go through the coursework
in this program you will get points
these points are grouped by achievements
and those achievements include
completing a lesson completing a course
running a pipeline
running a specific code block maybe
completing a session
and things like that
and then you will see your uh
program if you already registered for
the program
appear right here so you will be able to
see the programs that you're a part of
by going to this tab
and you can see here i have a list of
them so let's take a look at
how does this actually work
so if we go to the main site you can go
to programs
and this is the program that we are
discussing today machine learning for
biomedical drug discovery
and here you have the information about
the program itself with a little
overview of the program
all of the sessions
and then you will also see some of the
elements of the program
how they will fit together is the
subject of today's session so
we will provide you with training which
is a combination of
online sessions self-study guides that
you will find on this portal
including some practical exercises that
you'll be able to do
as you go through to build up your
technical skills
after you complete the coursework you
will get certificates
so all of our coursework is certified
and reviewed by multiple institutions
and partners
and so you will get a certificate that
you can share you will have
access to mentorship so the people that
you see
today in this program are some of the
mentors that will be available during
the program
depending on the level of your access
that you've purchased with the access to
the license
you will have an option to schedule a
meeting with
a mentor we'll also go over some of the
cloud tools today
so we'll show you how to utilize our big
data analysis platform
and we'll also show you how to utilize
some of the coursework
that includes practical skills that you
can develop right in the browser
importantly this is more than just a
training program essentially we view it
as a first step
to collaborate so those of you that are
joining today and starting with the
program
that's why we want you to complete your
profile your profile is going to be an
important place where others can learn
about you and connect with you
and hopefully you leave this program not
just
knowing how to do several things but
also getting connected
with people that you can form
long-term collaborations with so the
best way to do that
is actually to join our linkedin group
or a group on social media like facebook
how many of you are on linkedin
i'm on linkedin too much but
those of you that are on linkedin like
myself
you will be able to connect with me
obviously but also with all of us here
and the way to do that is to join our
omixlogic
group so i'll paste the link right here
okay why is it important to join a
media social media group of people that
are associated with omixlogic the reason
is because first of all
you will find that there are over 2 or
sorry 1 000 members here
that are experts in a variety of
different domains
including people that work for
biotechnology companies pharmaceutical
companies
faculty at different universities around
the world
including the us europe india
and other places you will find here
people that have completed our training
in the past and you see you will see how
they develop over time
we have our research fellows that post
here their research
project so you'll be able to see what
they have been able to do and achieve
and obviously all of us are here as well
so
if you hated the program you can tag us
if you love the program you can tag us
as well
so that's something that we encourage
all of you to do
in this program as well
okay so as i mentioned all of the
coursework
come with a certificate of completion so
let me briefly describe
what the certificate of completion is
and how to achieve that stage
so a program consists of several
different elements
these are going to be online sessions
that we will review in just a few
minutes
it includes some coursework that you
have to complete and it is certified as
well
and it also includes some of the
point-based system that we
have on our portal so the point-based
system
allows us and you to track your progress
as you go through the different stages
and assignments that are presented to
you in this program
so we expect everyone to get to a
minimum of
10 000 points and that gets you to a
level
of expertise that know that we all know
that you have completed some of the
basic training on the portal
once you reach a level of 10 000 points
you are also
eligible to work on an independent
project so all of you hopefully will get
to that point
and if you're interested in developing a
showcase
for what you have learned and maybe
how that aligns with your research
interests you are welcome to submit a
research project proposal
to submit a research project proposal
you will get a form
a personal invitation to submit a
project proposal
and once you submit it we will try to
assist you as much as possible
in completing that research project in
the duration of this program
if you want to continue and work on that
research proposal even after the program
is over you're welcome to do that you
have an option to join a
research fellowship program importantly
that research fellowship over the summer
will come
with a research symposium in august
where you will have access to experts
and
judges from top universities in the us
that will be able to comment
on your project presentation and so if
you're interested in that
please do reach out to our team so
malika here
dr mohit mazumdar myself you can reach
us out by
email sonarika if you could please list
out the emails here so
everyone would be able to join
okay so before i go on are there any
questions about this
how many of you have already joined the
linkedin group
all right perfect thank you priya has
anyone else joined the
all right great thank you nish
all right i see a few of you could i
repeat the part about points yes
so again the portal is free anyone can
join the portal and you have access to
some
free courses that you can go through and
kind of understand how they're
structured
for those of you that are part of the
program we will track your points
every time you complete an achievement
let me briefly show how
that works
okay so here you can go to this link
just type in achievements
you will see everybody and their
activity
on the portal
okay you can see that every time
somebody
completes some step like a lesson or a
course
you will get some points sometimes it's
15 sometimes it's one
sometimes it's 500 100 etc
and that's how you get to the 10 000
point mark
what are the courses that you consider
most important to complete okay so this
program
is about data science
so what i would recommend is go to this
tab courses
and start looking for introduction
you will see here the following courses
introduction to bioinformatics
introduction to data science and python
an introduction to data science and r if
you're just getting started
you can start with getting started with
bioinformatics and python
and getting started with bioinformatics
in r so these are some of the courses
that i recommend there's also
a course for those of you that need to
refresh
your molecular biology terminology and
kind of how does this all fit in
i recommend going through our course
called bites and molecules
isn't it possible to take up the
fellowship program after gaining 10 000
points
yes you can join the research fellowship
is a
program that you can learn about right
here go to research
and that program is designed
specifically for those of you that would
like to spend the next
three to six months working on
independent research projects
but those are again not relevant to this
program today so
let's go back to the program at hand
which is called
omics logic data science okay and i will
pass this on
very soon to my collaborator
dr sujeet who will speak about data
science
but i first want to make sure that we go
through this introduction
so our typical program on data science
includes the understanding of the
various omics data types formats
and associated challenges exploratory
data analysis
and processing that data to prepare for
analysis
application of supervised and
unsupervised machine
learning methods to exploration of
biomedical data
in this particular program we're going
to expand
the number of topics and we're going to
also talk about
things like deep learning neural
networks
we're going to talk about natural
language processing
and some other important tools that are
relevant to biomedical research but also
relevant to some of the other data types
however what we will try to do
is give you a complete roadmap for data
science so this is a month-long program
in this program you will find data sets
we will share with you some curated data
sets that you can practice with
you can explore and visualize making
sure that your visualization is
impactful
and accurate you will understand
research methods as you read through
publications
and you come across different figures
you'll understand what they represent
and hopefully that will give you insight
and understanding
of how to apply data science skills and
methods to a variety of biomedical
research topics
so that's why we call this avex logic so
onyx logic the purpose of this program
is really to connect the dots
and provide you with a variety of
different access points
so that you can continue and learn all
of these
important topics now briefly speaking
about
the sessions that are coming up today
we're talking about introduction to data
science
we will then talk about machine learning
algorithms
the application of data science to a
variety of domains including biomedical
research
on june 18th introduction to machine
learning for
next generation sequencing data
including transcriptomics genomics and
metagenomics
then we'll talk about unsupervised
machine learning clustering and data
mining
supervised machine learning
classification and finding different
signatures and big data and then we will
transition to a second part of the
program which will be focused on in
independent project so that is to
develop a proposal
on how you could apply machine learning
tools to
a variety of important topics in
biomedicine
or associated topics
we'll then do some practical hands-on
sessions which will include
dimensionality reduction in r and python
clustering in r in python classification
or in python
evaluating your model accuracy and how
to then
take your model to production and then
how to work
on an independent research project
okay so this is today's session so we
have
started today's session but we will
transition into the topic the
introduction to data science
in just a few more minutes and before we
get started i wanted to
give you an overview of how this will
work
okay so the important separation here is
that we have
two separate parts and so in the
beginning we will kind of get oriented
and introduced to the important topics
and then we will go into machine
learning and ai
and some practical hands-on tools and
i want to briefly tell you about how
different types of machine learning have
been
playing a big impact on biomedical
discovery
as you know the omix data types
continuously expand and evolve and so
it's important that
in many of these types of data there's
many many thousands of features
and because of that it is complicated to
apply
traditional statistical methods to
get accurate signal from this highly
variable and heterogeneous data
and so machine learning is very well
applied to the challenges
associated to big omics data and that's
why
you can see in literature and in a
variety of different
outlets how machine learning has been
taking over
this area of biomedical discovery drug
discovery
and the application of uh to research
to basic research challenges and
especially this can be seen
just by looking at the pace
of data coming out from different
biomedical projects
so this comes as a challenge but also
as an opportunity so on one hand the
challenge
is that the data is growing in
complexity
and growing in velocity growing in
volume
on the other hand it's an opportunity
because many of these data sets
are generated by extremely qualified
and skilled technicians laboratory
technicians as well as biologists that
ask the right questions and can generate
very accurate data about
very specific types of phenomena so when
we think about it
it's an opportunity if we just have the
tools to be able to work with this kind
of data
especially this can be seen with this
new pandemic
so as opposed to previous pandemics
and previous chronic diseases or even
some important developments around the
world epidemics that have sprung out in
different places
this pandemic has been characterized one
by huge volumes of data that have been
produced
number two real time sharing of such
data so it's not like the pandemic is
over and we're just getting access to
the data
every single day there have been
thousands of
new data points deposited in public
repositories that anyone can access
and number three this data has been
increa increasingly diverse that
includes genomic data
about the viruses themselves population
health data
about who and how peop get gets infected
and
how do they get sick including
transcriptomic data about the response
to the different types of infections
including many other different types of
data
and so now that we have this almost
real-time access to such biomedical data
the question is what can we actually do
with this data
and how can we utilize this data to gain
insights into what's going on
and to understand how we can gain
insights into this we need to understand
what are some of these technologies that
are generating
omix data to describe and characterize
the molecular drivers of these diseases
and this includes many different types
of omics data including
phenomics genomics epigenomics
transcriptomics metagenomics and many
others
now what's unique about this kind of
data is that this data has to be
processed so this data has to be
prepared before it could be analyzed
and that includes specific processing
steps
that are related to the way that this
data is generated and so what we'll do
in this program is also introduce you to
some of the tools
that you need to have to be able to
construct
logical workflows from raw data
to structure data and as a result as you
learn about the logic behind some of
these pipelines
you'll be able to prepare the data for
analysis and make sure that it answers
the specific question that you have in
mind
about this type of data now ultimately
the challenge is not just processing and
preparing the data for analysis but it's
in the integration of multiple different
data types
that are describing the same problem and
that includes
ability to perform statistical analysis
data mining structural analysis single
cell deconvolution
map these complex relationships and
ultimately
extract some meaningful insights so in
this program
we'll talk about all parts of this
process
from how the data was prepared to
generate the data set that we're looking
at to then data processing or how to
clean and organize the data and prepare
it for analysis
then we'll talk about exploratory data
analysis how we can
visualize and mine data for patterns to
eliminate
noise and focus on the signal and then
how to structure your analysis with a
specific strategy
to understand how different statistical
models
or different types of methods and
algorithms apply to a particular problem
and then how we can get some meaningful
insights or
inference what can we extract from this
type of analysis
that is relevant to the problem at hand
so
there's many different types of
unstructured data but the important part
is that
there's much more unstructured data than
structured data
and the problem with unstructured data
is that you can't really analyze it and
so
many data scientists unfortunately are
excited about
how we can apply different latest
techniques and models to
train on this data but if you don't have
access to structured data
essentially that's impossible so we will
spend some considerable time
talking about structuring data when you
structure data
data could be organized into many
different objects and so we will also
review
how different data objects and different
types of structures could be useful for
a variety of
information points that are in our
input data and so we'll talk about
vectors data frames matrices
arrays and others we'll talk about
data normalization and exploration to
understand
what are some of the prominent features
of the data and how we can
transform it into the data types and
data structures
that are most useful for different types
of analysis
and we will talk about some statistical
properties of data
that allow us to think about experiment
design
finally we will focus on some
biologically meaningful data analysis
and exploration so that we can
understand the different types of
visualization techniques and what they
mean
and go on to data mining and
classification and that includes
different types of classification
techniques and different types of
data mining approaches that again are
best used
in a variety of scenarios that we will
describe
using project examples
now many of you are probably coming to
this program
already knowing some coding and knowing
how to organize
your infrastructure on your own computer
but some of you might not be
and so what we wanted to do is to make
sure that this program is accessible to
those that
have a coding background and those that
do not so if you don't have any coding
background
that's absolutely okay we will go
through all of the basics
how is code organized and then you will
have an ability to
practice some of these things right in
your browser
before you take it out of the browser
and onto your computer so
how many of you already have rstudio
installed on your computer
okay priya mercelina okay
great excellent how many of you have
python
installed on your computer
okay great so what are some of your
what are some of your favorite
environments where you use python
so somebody mentioned pycharm anyone
else
collab okay jupiter jupiter
google collab vs code
all right excellent visual studio code
vs code
yep all right excellent so those of you
that
is there anyone here that does not have
rstudio installed yet
okay so for those of you that do not
have
let me show you for those of you that do
not have
our studio or python installed
you can go to introduction to
uh for example here you have here
directions
on how to do it rstudio and in the one
on python you have instructions on how
to get started with python
so what's important is that you need to
install several things on your computer
you need to get to know the environment
and you need to understand the logic
behind different packages
and different ways of running your code
so this is an important way to get
started for those of you that have
already
gotten that experience already you can
go on
into the more advanced topics there as
well
okay so we talked about coding
all right now the sessions that we will
have
like today's session are going to be
interactive sessions
that are going to be supplemented by
some of these online materials so it's
important to come to the session
when you are ready and so when you're
ready
you probably have to complete some
course or some lesson or some practical
assignment
and then that is the way that you can
leverage these
interactive sessions in the best way
possible so the interactive sessions are
to review you
they are to ask questions they are to
get help to get you
unstuck but to be a full part of the
program
you have to be an active participant so
for those of you that have already
joined the program we have a slack
channel
that you will get invited to after you
complete your registration
and so um how many of you have already
joined the slack channel
for this data science program
all right great all right so some of you
have if you have not
but you have already joined the program
then you need to ask us
you need to reach out to somalika
marketing at pine bio
she's our community manager and she will
help you get
set up so that you can ask questions you
can post your progress
or you can address any specific
challenges that you see
maybe something wasn't covered and
things like that now all of the sessions
are going to be recorded
so after the session is recorded it's
uploaded to our youtube channel
and you will get a recording right there
on the program page
as well as on the slack channel
alright so we already signed up let me
briefly show you
our big data analysis platform so that
all of you are
also signed up there
please go with me to server.tbio.info
and let me know if you are there you can
use
the exact same uh login and password
that you got
when you registered for the program
okay so anyone in fact that has
registered on the learn portal
will have an account for those of you
that
are not from are not a part of the
program yet you can still do a demo so
let me briefly demonstrate
what this platform does
okay please let me know once you're on
this link maybe put something in the
chat so i know you're there
all right thank you
all right anyone else i'll give it a
couple more minutes
priya thank you
all right so once you are logged in
and i can see that i'm logged in just by
hovering over this profile
icon let's go and we'll try
two things so as you can see this
platform is organized into the following
sections this is
for big data processing and here you
have some
things that you can try without any
coding so i will show you two things
the first one is an example of a
processing pipeline
so i'll go into this demo there's no
need to upload anything but it helps you
understand the logic behind the analysis
so you can see here the different steps
you can then perform
pre-processing or cleaning up the raw
data and filtering it for all kinds of
technical variation
then we perform mapping and so you learn
about the reeds and the exons and how
they are spliced together to form
transcripts then you can find
how the transcripts are added on into
the annotation file or the gtf file
and then finally finally how do we
quantify
the abundance of gene expression so one
of the data types we will
deal with is gene expression and that is
transcriptomic data
so here you will find some of the
outputs that you will need
to work with transcriptomic data from a
curated project that you can learn about
on our
portal okay so this was example number
one
example number two once you have that
data already
you can perform what's called principal
component
analysis and inside of this pipeline
you will also get code
for r studio so if you want to modify
the code
and you want to run it on your computer
you can do it from right here so again
this platform combines big data
processing
directly from ncbi or from your own
computer
with downstream analysis techniques many
of them
are implemented in r and you will be
able to download the r script from right
here
okay so any other questions before we
move on
okay if there are no other questions i
want to introduce our speaker for today
dr sujit
he is the founder of pharmatoppers and
the co-founder of octam
pvt ltd he has a phd in chemo
informatics and drug design
as well as ai in drug discovery
durba we will address all the other
questions at the end of the session so
please hold on to your questions
and sujeed i will pass it on to you
thank you
i welcome again all of you guys
and good morning good afternoon good
evening wherever you are
part of the globe so let me share my
screen
could you please confirm if my screen is
visible
yes sir it's visible thank you
so guys uh as a part of entire one month
program this is an
introduction to data science how we can
use it for a life science
in this program i would be talking more
on a data science perspective
and that something about some
mathematical part of a data science and
machine learning
what exactly is happening but definitely
i'll correlate most of the terminologies
most of the things to the life science
or the pharma pharma
data
so considering that we have
participants from various background
maybe from life science maybe
from genomics maybe maybe from parma and
maybe from a computer science
so guys have you ever wondered how
amazon ebay suggests items for you to
buy
you used to get some notifications right
have you
do you know gmail filters your email uh
before it comes to you
as a spam or not not non-spam categories
hope you you might be knowing many of
time you might have seen that okay my
my email has gone my email has gone into
spam folder
maybe google can tag that particular
email as a spam
if you are watching netflix if you are a
regular customer of netflix
so do you know netflix predicts how uh
what are the shows you like
i mean let's see if you are watching any
video or any movie in a netflix
and netflix also gives some suggestion
based on your base on your activity
previous activity
into the platform but do you know all
these things are actually
a part of ai or actually part of machine
learning deep learning or
broadly we can say your data science so
apart from this these examples are
actually considered to a very general
public to just getting into this
particular program
but if i have to specifically talk about
life science
or pharmacy graduate or any uh
any other bioinformatics graduate so
guys if you have no we can predict the
toxicity of
a drug molecule using data science using
machine learning using deep learning
uh if you are a life science graduate
you know
you can draw a molecular structure
in a various molecule editor tools
once you draw a structure you can save
the structure into a
image a 2d image of the molecule in a
png format
also along with the image you can
predict the toxicity of a molecule there
has been several paper
people have published about how we can
predict the toxicity of molecule just
from an image
so this is all of this is because of the
computer vision technology which is also
part of data science
so guys you can do many things using
data science or using machine learning
deep learning uh
if you have heard about there are
several other companies out there in the
market like benevolent ai
excentia and several other startup
companies now they are becoming a giant
pharma companies they have already
partnered with several companies like
astrazeneca
pfizer very big companies know what is
etc and uh as you know the
entire drug discovery process it
actually takes around
15 to 20 years and around four billion
dollars
of cost to to have entire drug discovery
process
but the act the entire discovery process
has been reduced down to
only one year just because of the ai
just because of the
ai and drug discovery so if you are a
life science graduate if you if you are
a farmer pharma graduate if you are
a phd or if you are a research
researcher we would request all of you
to
apply data science machine learning or
artificial intelligence technologies in
your day-to-day
research activities or it is a highly
recommended
course for each each one of you
so uh how you can define a data science
or a data scientist you know
the one who knows data science the one
who works in the field of data science
is actually called as a data scientist
in a industry so at the bottom if you
can see a person who is better at
statistics
than any software engineer and better at
software engineering than any
statistician
is actually called as a data scientist
and you could have heard about data
jobs data scientist jobs are the most
loved
jobs and you could find many vacancies
out there in the market for data science
and in this course we have another
course starting from tomorrow where in
vr
we are giving practical sessions on a
chemo informatics and a drug discovery
if you could join both of this course
you will have complete idea
understanding of how we can apply
data science in our machine learning or
deep learning
in in your drug discovery process or in
your biological or chemical data
so moving forward data science is a
practice of mining large data set of raw
data both structured and unstructured
so here structured you can say a label
data a label data you can say
the let's say you if you have a
particular sentence let's say for a
particular molecule you know that is
that benzene's kind of structure is
actually a benzene molecule and
let's say if particular molecule is
actually a paracetamol molecule
if you know any data point which belongs
to any particular
tax that is called a structure data but
let us say you have a bunch of
molecules but you don't know uh the name
of those molecules or you if you don't
know smiles of those molecules you just
have those images of those molecule
then actually that is called as a
unstructured data
so data science is a practice of mining
large data to identify patterns and
extract actionable insights from them
so actually this is an interdisciplinary
field
it includes statistics if you are
to be called as a data scientist you
need to have you need to know some of
the statistics
you should have some understanding of a
computer science you should have some
predictive analytics capability
you should know machine learning deep
learning a little bit of machine
learning deep learning computer vision
or natural language processing and you
should you should be
capable enough to find out some of the
inferences
from your data and
existence of this data science
technologies like machine learning and a
data saving
data data thirsty algorithms like deep
learning came just because of the big
data
so if you could see if you are a human
being you are actually
generating a data and then with data
scientist
he actually does some analysis of the
data and then data scientists give
inference or a prediction of prediction
based on that data by applying some
algorithms techniques
so uh let us talk about data
and their languages what actually
important for a
data science as a data scientist why we
are learning data science is
just because why this why this
particular field came into existence why
this machine learning deep learning
everyone is using this algorithm
just because data is growing
exponentially and yes for machine
learning deep learning or any other data
science algorithm
the data is actually a fuel for those
algorithm and you know
data is not only fuel for the algorithm
but yes also for the entire world
so uh the inter and as you might be
knowing internet users are generating
more than two point point billion spear
bytes of a data every day so
about 90 percent of this huge amount of
data gets generated in the most recent
two years
according to the sources like ibm and
snippy
so and you can even in the coming days
coming coming years you could see even
more number of zetabyte of data could
may generate in every
hour or every day so uh being a data
scientist what exactly
you should know what are those libraries
i would more focus on a python but yes
being a data site
scientist if you know r you can work you
can
you can use many of those algorithms and
you can do lots of data analysis process
using r uh i am a python expert i
i like python because you could find
more of a libraries
related to data science in a python
python uh framework
so uh me out of the several
data science libraries pandas is the
number one library
which is actually most important data
scientists should learn about
numpy scipy numpy is for the
mathematical calculations
scipy is also for some calculations
scrappy if you wanna
scrap some data matplotlib if you wanna
plot some uh plot some
data statistics analysis if you wanna do
you can use sebum as well
psychic land contains several machine
learning algorithms wherein you just
have to call the package and you can
you can you go good to go to develop
your own model
and again psychic image tensorflow and
librosa can be used also
for can be these are the very useful
packages for
any data scientist beginner or expertise
so uh okay as we are talking about data
science so let me directly jump into
data science life cycle what exactly the
steps involve
being a part of data science day to day
activities data scientist day to day
activities
so and then after this data science life
cycle we will look it into
all other machine learning deep learning
uh all other algorithms and there
and there's some some mathematics behind
those algorithm as well
along with some life science specific to
life science problems or a specific tool
as a life science examples so what could
be the first step
being a data scientist what you would do
very
as a first step or how data science
workflow works on
so defining defining a problem statement
to work with any data science problem or
any any
uh any uh to to so to to bring data
science
approach to any of the problem you
should have a perfect well-defined
problem statement
if you don't have you can work on to
define perfect problem statement
then the way the biggest the most
important step is data collection
having a very good amount of data and
having a good quality of data is
actually a
very strong strong base for
any any data modeling process or data
science life cycle
you need to collect good good quality of
data you need to have
amount of the quantity could be anything
i mean
there are several algorithms which can
work on a less amount of data but yes
you should have always a good quality of
a data
you we should always focus on a quality
rather than more on a quantity
so data collection is actually a
systematic approach to gather relevant
information from a variety of sources
and this data collection which you can
actually use using data mining
algorithms
i mean some data mining techniques and
also you can do web strapping for data
collection
and also there are several open source
repositories out there in the market
wherein you can download the data and
you can start practicing
and developing your very first model we
can say hello world model
machine learning hello world machine
learning model so to download the data
we have several websites like github you
can go and login into github we have
kaggle it's a competition uh platform
wherein you can find
a lot of large amount of data for
different purpose and we have a data hub
once as i mentioned once you have a
proper data once you collect data from
various sources
then the next very the neck the next
important step is data quality check and
remediation
it's always important to have quality of
data as i mentioned
there is a simple terminology in a data
science field like you know
whatever you feed into machine uh
whatever you feed into algorithm maybe
machine learning or deep learning
algorithm
you will get out from that the same if
you garbage if you got
if you feed the garbage you will get
garbage out of it if you fit good
quality of data you will get good
protection out of it
so data analysis and data
cleaning processing is actually a very
important step in a data science life
cycle
being a part of data science life cycle
so uh let's say once you have a cross
secure data once you have
uh once you define yes your data quality
quality is too good
then uh the another important step is
data analysis
so uh at the end of the life cycle i'll
tell you what are those
out of this all those steps what is
actually the important step in the
entire data science data
data science life cycle so data data
analysis is like you know you have to
find out what kind of data you have you
can plot
your data points into different using
different pie chart bar
bar bar diagram or any other uh any
other
plotting tools like of matplotlib and c
bond and uh
you need to explore your data before
feeding into machine learning you
also need to find out okay do do i have
combination of genes combination of
protein sequences
do i have smile structures along with a
descriptors or a fingerprint
you need to check your data completely i
mean you need to analyze your data
completely
so once you analyze you can segregate
your data let's say you if you are if
you
you just wanted to work on a gene part
you can you can put only
gene related data or uh or
you can you can put descriptors or a
fingerprint to the machine learning
model
so the very next step is once you have
crosstrack your data once you have a
good quality of data and once you know
my data is ready to go to machine
learning modeling process
so the the next step is data modeling
modeling means actually the formulating
every step and gather techniques
required to achieve the solution
so here it comes actually a various
algorithms exact algorithms like you
know machine learning algorithms like
random forex support vector machine
and deep learning algorithms and also uh
you can you can say
uh other subpart of deep learning like
you know
and cnn and other things so what are the
common tools which
public you currently are using and which
is uh which is
currently available in the market as a
free of cost maybe some are
paid one is a matlab which is paid one
but we have a veka
we have sas enterprise miner we have
alpine miner we have
statistica and spcs modeler these are
some of the freely available tools which
you can find out in a market you just
need to import a data
into the software and you just have to
select a
algorithm which through which algorithm
you have to build your model and you are
you will uh more this tools will give
you
all the predictions and
uh but let's say a tool has given you
the prediction uh
so it could be you know the accuracy all
the validation parameters could be
accuracy
sensitivity specificity specificity and
all other stuff
but yes you should able to communicate
your result as well
i mean let's say if you have some kind
of classification problem so you should
develop your classification model and
while showing it to user or while
communicating your results to the
other third party you should always have
accuracy
or mcc score or all other classification
scores
if you have regression problem
definitely guys this terminology might
be
new to you classification regression but
in coming in coming slides we will we
will
look at into all those terminology in a
deep so
let's say if you have a regression
problem then you how you are
communicating your results whether it's
r square value or rmse or whatever you
have to
express or you have to communicate your
results proper results to the
stakeholders or the third part
third-party person so
and most often you need to present your
findings to a non-non-technical audience
such as marketing team or a business
executive
so you need to communicate the results
in a simple to understand
in a simple and understanding manner
so uh by collecting all these steps so
you know
first is a data discovery you mean you
can say data gathering
data preparation model planning model
building operation operationalization
and communicate result so you know guys
the first step second
second step are actually the most
important uh
this is my personal experience if you if
you ask me i
i have been into this fields more than
around 10 years into uh
and i have several years of experience
in industry and academy as well
in the same field and i was i was
applying even i am applying
uh data science machine learning fields
in a biomedical data or in a life
science data or in pharma data
so uh being a data scientist i would
more focus on a data part because i
as i mentioned whatever you feeding into
machine learning you will get out of it
if you if you if you feed garbage you
will get garbage out of it if you fit
good quality of data
you will get better protection out of it
so that's why i more focus on a data
data part and data cleaning part data
pre-processing part
and data analytics analytics and
exploratory parts
then uh you know data scientists they
they plan which
based on the data which algorithm should
i go which algorithm should i use
whether my machine learning suffice my
need or i should jump into deep learning
or this is the problem of
natural language processing this all a
part of a
model planning then you'll do model
building using those algorithms and then
you will communicate those results so
guys
as of now please let me know if you have
any questions on this
uh if you have any questions you can
unmute yourself and
you can you can ask me questions
so iron ask how is the drug structure
drawn so there are several
online open source software tools
available
uh maybe after this session we can put
all those links to this chat box
so considering that we don't have any
questions
as of now okay
okay so guys let us let us speak
something about
why these are so data scientists machine
learning artificial intelligence
and deep learning natural language
processing computer vision
let us differentiate all other
terminologies one by one one by one in
the coming slides
so actually ai data science and machine
learning all work in a tandem
machine learning is a field of actually
data science that fits computers huge
amount of data
so so they can learn to make insightful
decisions similar to
the way that humans do for example let's
say
let us take some a random example from
your day to day life and then again
we'll move into your life science data
so most humans learn so children uh what
you
learn as a children what a flaw is
without thinking about
it however the the human brain achieves
that
learning through experience by
collecting data on which specific
feature are associated
with the flower let's say if you're if
you if you could
if you are seeing the rose as a flower
every day
based on those features red color that
shape
size height everything based on that you
will identify this particular flower
could be an
uh rose similar way
we have to feed few features to a
machine let's say if we are building a
model for a pipe
for a flower so we have to feed those
features to
a machine saying that okay this
particular flower has a red color these
have some height this is the shape for a
flower
this is a dimension this this flowers
actually comes in
this particular time frame this could be
a part of big three small tree
these all all the actually parameters or
features for those floor once we feed
into those features
machine will understand okay this
features belongs to the rows
and then finally machine will predict
okay this this
if particular features come in the
future then machine will understand okay
yes
this is this is actually a flower let me
give you one another example which is
actually booming
currently in new channel everywhere like
autonomous self-driving cars right
so how these cars are actually working
on
so let's say driverless cars right so
if somebody is i mean nobody's driving
the car
in a driverless car but if some some any
object comes in front of the car let's
say
cat or a dog target stops over there if
the brake automatically
the system in a car they will they will
they will uh
they'll put the brakes down right why so
this is this is called a computer vision
problem so let me let me tell you this
camera in a car
they will capture the image okay let's
say if cat come in
in front of the car the camera will
capture okay this is a
car cat photo okay then machine learning
it will it will derive all the features
from from that image and from that
features already they have trained all
the
features of the cat using machine
learning or deep learning algorithm
and based on those features machine
learning will or deep learning will
predict
okay this these are actually features
for a cat and then
we have to stop just because cat has
come
in front of the car and we have to stop
our car right away
because it has come in front of our car
so this is how
deep learning machine learning or data
science field works
so a machine can do same thing with a
human as human feeds the machine
massive quantities of data it can learn
that various petals steam and other
features all connected to a
floor at the same example uh if i have
to take an example
in uh in our uh let's say chemistry
point of view
uh you if you are aware with the chemo
informatics if you are aware with the
chemical data so let's say if you have a
paracetamol molecule you you have a 2d
structure or a 3d structure of a
paracetamol molecule
then the next step is what exactly you
have to do you have to calculate the
features of paracetamol
the features could be paracetamol have
an oh group paracetamol have carboxylic
group it has a benzene ring
so you have all those features of those
paracetamol
so then you have to feed in those
features into
algorithm could be a machine learning
random for a support vector machine
k means any algorithm and then
machine will predict okay if such
features are there so these features are
actually belongs to palace at the mall
if
in the future if any such kind of
features come into into this model
the model will predict okay this this
features are actually belongs to
paracetamol and then it will predict
yes this this molecule is a paracetamol
molecule so this is how
this this uh machine learning data
science or deep learning
actually works so i'll again these are
just a superficial example i'll go and
i'll go in a very deep to explain you
what
how exactly it works how what
mathematics is behind
all those algorithms
okay
any questions so far guys
yeah so as i mentioned there are several
uh terminologies out there right so data
science artificial intelligence machine
learning deep learning natural language
processing and computer vision these are
all terminologies
you can say a part of the data science
okay now you might have heard all these
terminologies now
let's understand what exactly these are
and why we are learning about
it right so you you can say data science
is a kind of a big
bubble uh similar to that big data is a
actually also a big bubble so
artificial intelligence is is another
bubble in a data science or is actually
a part of a data science
and then machine learning comes into
a completely comes into artificial
intelligence and then neural networks
uh you might have heard about
multi-layer perceptron these are
part of a neural network so this neural
network comes into a
machine learning uh domain and then we
have a deep neural network
so if we have a single layer it is
called simple neural network if we have
a multiple layers more than two
so it is called a deep neural network or
a deep learning it is also comes
comes as a part of a neural network so
hierarchy is like data science is a very
big bubble
in that we have artificial intelligence
into that we have a machine learning
into that we have neural network center
and and finally a small bubble which
comprises all this
uh deep neural networks or deep learning
so now
hope you understand how this how this
terminologies are actually linking and
why we are
we have why we are calling all these
terminologies several times
okay so with this
let us move on each and every uh
categories i would say or algorithms or
broader categories of algorithms one by
one
so let us talk about machine learning
so uh you know guys before going forward
before moving forward let me
uh again explain you uh let's say
there is a small baby there is a small
child we
uh we we teach him every time okay uh
this is a spoon this is how you have to
talk this is how you have to call this
is how
uh this is this is how you have to get
out of your bed this is how you have to
walk
so we feeding every each and every
information to the child right
so likewise this algorithms or you can
say this machine
we have to feed each and every
information to the machine
and uh another example
you might have seen the robot movie from
the rajnikanth if you are
if you are a part of india and uh let's
say
how the rope how the brain of that robot
works you know this is
everything is artificial intelligence it
contains
as you've seen as you have seen it is a
it is maybe a combination of machine
learning deep learning neural networks
all those algorithms
so this robot brain is actually
artificial intelligence so
while developing while creating a robot
all while developing a robot brain
they are they feed each and every
information to the robot
this is how you have to walk this is how
you have to jump this is how
you have to get in from your bed this is
how you have to
take a spoon all these things they
they'll teach uh
they'll teach to robot so this is a
machine
wherein you have to teach this machine
as a child
okay so let us let us go a small
definition of machine learning
so machine learning algorithms enables
the computer to learn from a data
and even improves themselves without
being explicitly programmed
so as you uh so what exactly this
definition meaning is you know
initially you have to feed data to the
machine and then
based on your data machine can
understand okay this is how i have to
act this is how
i have to react but in the further
events
eventually machine keeps on learning
themselves
let's say in the let's say in further if
you feed if you keep on feeding the data
and whatever machine is predicting
based on his experiences machine keeps
on
learning whatever he has predicted
whether this prediction is correct or
not
if it is correct it will understand if
it is not next time it will avoid to do
that particular wrong prediction so this
is how machine learning works and
without being explicitly programmed
means you don't have to tell each and
every time
so actually we have to make our
algorithm or our
pipeline so that our algorithm should
learn
itself in a further in a subsequent
subsequent event
of our process so machine learning is a
category of algorithm that allows
software application to become more
accurate in predicting outcomes without
being explicitly programmed
so like google if you are typing
something let's say if you are searching
for
a shoes in a google very next day or
maybe in next two or three days
you will get several ads from a shoes
companies to your
maybe to your gmail maybe to or maybe in
your any of the social media sites maybe
if you are browsing through
facebook these ads will come up auto
automatically
because they'll understand okay you
google will i mean this uh this
algorithms at the back end they have
algorithm
so they'll understand okay you are
searching for issues and they'll
immediately they'll keep on showing
those shoes ads to your your
your browsing panel wherever it is
whether it is a browser whether it is a
social media
might be facebook or anywhere
so the basic premise of machine learning
is to build algorithm that can receive
input data and use statistical analysis
to predict an output while updating
output as a new data becomes available
so uh again while building a model there
are several steps which i'll
let you know i mean we have to divide
our data into training say
test set validation data and we can
build a model using training set and we
can use test data to
to to find out how my model performs
very well for unknown data and again on
a validation data
so let me let me walk you each and every
step in
a coming slide
so machine as i said machine learning is
used everywhere from automating tasks to
offering intelligent
insights industries in every sector try
to benefit from it
you can apply machine learning
algorithms in business
in your life science data in finance
in iit sector if you have to manage your
computer processing or if you have to
find when
when your computer that is called ml ops
if you have to find when your computer
is going to get
shut down in in in how many hours you
can
you can even predict using machine
learning if you have to find out
at what time period your your computer
heartache is gonna
get full you can you can again you can
find this information or you can predict
this using machine learning
and other examples are like you know
drugs classification you can classify
all your drugs let's say
if you are a chemist you can you can
classify your drugs on let's say
benzopyral category or indole containing
green category
or many other chemical class categories
you can you can predict the toxicity of
molecules and you can generate even new
molecules
using machine learning there are several
companies like astrazeneca
pfizer they have they have generated new
molecule without being synthesized in a
lab they have generated new molecules
using
gan generative uh generative networks
there are even several algorithms out
there you know
out there uh so where by which you can
generate a new molecule
and uh you might have heard natural
language processing
you can generate a new sentence if you
are talking something machine can
machine can generate new sentences after
your after your sentence
so these are all everything can be
possible uh using
all this data science or machine
learning technologies and the very best
example is like you know
uh you have you you might be wearing
these fitbit bands and
you might be using google home or siri
or alexa in your day to day
activity these are all these are all
possible just because of this
ai world or data science world or the
machine learning deep learning
algorithms so i hope
you don't have any questions so far
yes so we have one question is same
machine learning work in computer chess
game
yes uh in a competition also they
we have ai system yes exactly
so guys if you feel shy to ask questions
publicly
uh uh by admitting your mic you can you
can please
type your question in a chat box pia
opal has
said please explain mlp please i assure
you priya will have several slides over
after this about nlp and other
algorithms as well
so guys uh let us speak down something
into a history of artificial
intelligence or history of a data
science how
when it has started so actually uh
these algorithms were available uh to
the scientific community
late in 1950s uh but you know because of
a lack of data
because of uh proper data because
that time data big data technologies was
not there
so because of that we we were not having
organized data enough
in a public resource so that's why this
algorithm although they
there were this algorithm but nobody was
using this algorithm and
another point is like computational
power previously
if you have seen early 19th century
computer or early 1950s 1960s computer
they are actually very big
computers now you have the entire a
computer like uh like they may occupy
entire room now those
such big computers have came down into
your laptop or
even you can uh maybe you're a small
desktop or something
so that's why this algorithm was in a
hidden state
we can say even i can say but yes
eventually
uh this algorithm came into picture many
people where you
start using many people have start using
these algorithms and they start
modifying their algorithm based on the
data and
they were getting very proper output
once the data is available to
those algorithm so i i can say 1990s or
2000
could be a very good point to start with
i mean people have started using machine
learning algorithm everywhere
and eventually after 2010 or
in between 2000 uh 2000 to 2015 we could
see
the evolution of a deep learning uh
many researchers from google and
facebook they
they developed several algorithms
and they published they made it a pub
they made it free to public
uh you have all those deep learning
algorithm and other computer vision and
nlp algorithms
so just a minute
yes luis so yes the goal of this entire
course is you know we will we will
explain you each and everything this is
being a very fast
first session so we wanted each and
everyone to be to bring on a single
platform so that's why we are explaining
everything to correlate with your
day-to-day life but yes from the next
session
we will we will we will give each and
every example related to pharmaceutical
or life sign
okay so
what are the uh so you you understood
what exactly machine learning is
so then let us learn something about
what are the types of
uh machine learning so yes there are
different types of machine learning
one is the supervised machine learning
second is the unsupervised machine
learning and third one is the
reinforcement learning
so the very first is a supervised
machine learning so in the supervised
machine learning
we have a classification and regression
so as i mentioned let's say guys let me
directly jump into example and then i'll
explain you what exactly it is
so let's say again talking on a
biomedical perspective let's say you
have a set of
molecules and you need to find out
whether this particular molecule could
pass a
blood brain barrier or not okay so you
will have a two set of molecules one set
of
molecules would be those molecules which
could pass blood brain barrier
and another set of molecules which
doesn't pass blood blood brain barrier
okay and you have labeled all those
molecules let's say
molecule one crosses blood brain barrier
molecule two yes crosses blood brain
barrier molecule 3 doesn't cross blood
print barrier
molecule 4 yes crosses molecule 5
doesn't cross
so let's say you have such such kind of
molecules maybe you have
a 1000 molecules and out of thousands
for you could cross blood print barrier
and rest of the
sorry 500 could cause blood brain
variant and rest of the 500
may not cross blood-brain barrier okay
so this is called a label data right
so you have all those molecules and you
know these molecules can
cross or cannot cross blood brain
barrier so this is called a label data
so using this label data and the and as
you have only two
classes you you can say categories right
you have whether it is cross
it will not cross this is a kind of a
true or false example right
so you can say such kind of examples as
a classification example
okay again let me let me give you some
real time i mean real life example or a
day-to-day
example let's say if you wanna predict
how price of a house
price of a house could be you know uh
milli
uh one million dollar few thousand
dollars or could be 300 3.5 million
dollars right
so so this price of a house could be uh
could be a uh what i can say
variable right this this variable is the
continuous variable i mean
you have those values this is not kind
of a true or false
you are not for predicting the price of
a house
you you cannot do true whether it is
true or whole but you have to predict
some values out of it
right so such if you have uh
if you want to predict some values then
you have to use some
regression problem hope you understood
uh
what this classification and regression
again if you
so classification algorithm can be used
for you know image classification as i
mentioned using a
2d molecular structure you can predict
whether this molecule is a toxic or a
non-toxic so it could be a it can be an
image classification problem
so you can you can identify fraud
detection
i mean you can let's say you have
two types of let's see if i'm up if i'm
working on a banking data
and you have all the transaction main a
few of the transaction might be a
normal transaction and a few of the
transaction could be a fraud transaction
you can take those transaction details
and you can build machine learning model
and you can if the new transaction comes
in you can easily identify whether this
transaction is a pro transaction or a
normal transaction by the customer
or by the bank user
so uh uh for regression model like you
know
you can uh uh the kind of examples are
like you know advertising popularity
prediction where you can do weather
forecasting
you can do market forecasting there are
several other algorithm for forecasting
as well like
lstm and rn and algorithm
so there are several other use cases of
classification regression algorithm
in your research activity also in your
day-to-day life okay so
unsupervised machine learning algorithm
this is also another part of a
machine learning algorithm so as i
mentioned if you have a label data could
be a
house price could be a toxic or
non-toxic could be a fraud or a
non-profit transaction
whether you have to forecast your
weather i mean
these are all the label data i mean the
data which you have
it is completely labeled you know this
data belongs to this particular category
so that category or that variable is
actually called as a y variable later on
coming coming sessions i'll explain you
how we define x
variable variable in the uh algorithm in
the machine learning algorithm
so uh so if you have a label data you
can go for a supervised machine learning
algorithms and if you have unsupervised
let's say guys
you have a random data maybe let's say
if somebody many
any of you have gone to web sources
website several website
and you just copy pasted the random data
into different files or in a single file
you have copy pasted several sentences
you know you might have
gathered all the images from the google
images
maybe a thousand images from the google
images and you have gathered in the one
place
but you don't know which image belongs
to which data or otherwise
you don't have that time to label that
data if if you
if you have brought up if let's say
out of those thousand images there may
be a hundred cat images or
500 eleven elephant images but you don't
have time to
classify those images or you don't have
time to label those images
or you you have you you have just random
data
could be any case right in that case
it means you don't have a label data so
it means
in this in such cases it is called
unsupervised machine learning algorithm
in in such cases we have to use
unsupervised machine learning algorithm
and this is called an unsupervised
problem or unsupervised classification
problem
so how you tackle this such problems uh
in a different way right so there could
be a two problems one is a clustering
another is a dimensionality reduction
so so you know uh the way
it should not be a part of actually
unsupervised but yes you know here
in the you will just gain some uh
meaningful insights from the data using
dimensionality reduction
uh maybe uh you can you can you can
calculate those features and you can get
only selected features for
for those data but yes the very
important algorithm uh the set of
algorithms are you know clustering
algorithms
so there are several k means clustering
there are several algorithms which can
help you out to make a
as this algorithm the category clearly
defines that it's a clustering
so let's say you have a random thousand
the
images algorithm itself based on your
image features based on your image data
based on your images it will create
several clusters
either you have to define okay i need 10
clusters or i need 15 clusters
or if you don't define machine this
algorithm itself they create a cluster
so let's say it makes create a clusters
of those animals
maybe one cluster contain all those
animal images another cluster contains
maybe city images another cluster may
contain electronic gadget images
or such kind of images it will it will
cluster so this is called a clustering
algorithm okay
so what you can kind of real like
example you know customer segmentation
so let's say you have a website
and a lot of traffic traffic is coming
into your website and you have to
traffic in the sense lot of visitors are
visiting your website
right so uh you have to categorize those
those users into different categories
whether they belongs to
they belongs to a business people
whether they belongs to industry
employees whether they belongs to a
government employees you can categorize
those those users into different
categories using clustering algorithm
okay so i'll go through each and every
question
after this session uh maybe i can
reserve five or ten minutes for the
question and answer
so another algorithm could be a
reinforcement learning
so one of our fellow they he asked
whether we can use uh
this algorithm into a gaming right yes
yes we inform
reinforcement learning is actually using
in various games
mostly in a chase and other other game
so this
so this this algorithm is used for you
know in robot navigation
real time decisions learning task skill
acquisition
so how this algorithm can use for robot
navigation right
so maybe it's better if i explain you
with all those images uh
in a coming slide
so let us go deep dive into
uh into those supervised unsupervised
machine learning algorithms
uh sunalika i have a question for you
shall i continue for another 10 to 15
minutes or should we stop this session
here and we can
we can open platform for a question and
answer
anyone can answer to my question
okay guys let us quickly look at uh this
supervised
all this description whatever i have
explained you let us quickly
look at this algorithm and then i look
i'll be answer i'll answer all of your
questions so classification as i
mentioned you know
you can classify various diseases this
is or no disease
uh whether it is a which color red blue
maybe any kind of this could be
there should not be you know this should
not be always
only two types whether it is a true or
false or red or black or
pieces or notices there could be a
multiple categories as well you know
maybe protein okay this drugs belongs to
protein one protein two protein three or
protein four
here we have four different categories
right so that could that is called a
multi-class classification or a
multi-label product classification
if we if any drug belongs to protein one
or either protein 2 or
protein 3 or protein 4 that is called
multi-class classification or
if one drug may belongs to protein 1 and
protein 2 or maybe protein 1 and protein
4 or maybe protein 2 and protein 4.
that is called multi-label
classification okay guys
and we have as as we discussed
regression regression problem is when
the output variable is the real value
could be a drug activity if you have to
find out a drug activity biological
activity of a molecule
if you you have to find out the
molecular weight of a molecule
if you you have to find out uh
uh ic50 or k k 10
all other parameters the algorithm which
you you will use for
supervised and unsupervised algorithm
are you know linear regression logistic
regression k
nearest neighbors decision tree random
forest gradient boosting machines xg
boos
support vector machines and also neural
networks
so for unsupervised learning as i
mentioned let's say you have a random
set of
data at right side you could see a
computer will
automatically clusters those the data
into different different clusters
and output is dependent upon the
algorithm which algorithm you
you are going to use it so in the
unsupervised learning
uh clustering and association as i as i
discussed the algorithm which you are
gonna use is you know k means clustering
hierarchy
clustering and neural networks can also
be used for unsupervised machine
learning
and in a maybe in the next section we
will look it into reinforcement learning
this is a very interesting algorithm
wherein you know you will get
uh how exactly robot gets navigation
uh through through those algorithm how
we feed in data into those uh those
algorithms
and these are some tools or we you can
say some open source
uh platforms available for all the data
scientists to work on
such kind of problem so i would like to
walk you through
some demo but definitely next session
will i i'm gonna walk you through
some code demo how we can write those
machine learning algo i mean
uh this code how we can use this machine
learning for our problem
we don't have to explicitly write a code
or we don't have to do all such
mathematics
being a biological student being a
chemistry background student i don't
have to write all this algorithm there
are several packages available out there
we just have to call the package we just
have small understanding of
python and we just have to call those
packages and we are good to go
we can use we just have to fit in data
and we have to call those packages and
machine will does everything and it will
give us the prediction
in the coming slides we have several
other i'll explain you how deep learning
works what are the formulas for deep
learning
what what exactly mathematics behind
deep learning
no i'll not go much deeper into the
mathematics but yes i'll definitely
correlate how you can
let's see if you are feeding your
molecular structures into
a network let's say in this network so
how how this calculation exactly
happening and how this particular
thing it is producing whether it is a
particular molecule i have
here i have taken an example of dog and
cat but yes
it will i'll explain you how you have
let's see if you have fit in
gene expression data if you have feeding
molecular descriptor or a fingerprint
what exactly happening in this hidden
layer input layer and output layer i'll
explain you
a little bit of method with a little bit
of mathematics
and uh and we have lot more stuff to
cover in the coming lectures
uh in the entire session of one month so
it could be a very interesting uh
journey
with you guys me and with my other
fellow colleagues
from our collaborators and uh we will
so this could be a very great starting
point for you
to jump into if you are not completely
new about data science it could be a
great starting point for you to jump
into data science field
and if you want to change your field
maybe you are working we have several
people from the industry if you really
want to change your career
this could be a i don't say this is a
blockbuster course but yes
this could be a starting point for you
based on this course you will learn many
things how
what exactly you can do in your data
science we have seen several students or
several people
being a pharmaceutical graduate bringing
a
biological being a life science graduate
they have implemented
this algorithm they have used this
technologies
in in their own data in their pharma
data in their drug discovery data
in their life science gene expression
data and they developed several good
models or good softwares out of it and
they got very well recognition
in the in their industry or in their
research for
so guys i am hoping all of you for a
for a next one month journey association
with all of you
and definitely you and our team will
enjoy this entire one month session on a
data science and you will learn many
things about data science
in the coming days so now i am open for
uh question uh
hello sir sorry sir we were not there
when you called us we were in a meeting
and uh so we have a question on youtube
i just wanted to ask that
so uh el cary asks i'm not a data
scientist but i'm looking forward to use
machine learning especially genomic and
transatomic data analysis in my research
but he doesn't know how he can start and
he's asking which things could
help him to initiate himself in the
field and make progress as quick as
possible
and that is i think the common question
of a lot many people as well
so could you please tell uh how people
who want to make a career in data
science
how they can start yes yes thanks thanks
sonalika
so guys uh as i already mentioned
being a life science graduate even if
you don't have any
experience in a python any experience in
data science any experience in
machine learning that is that is also
fine this data science
course the entire one month course is
actually designed for for you guys
if you don't have any understanding of
of a computer science or
of a prop python programming or anything
in this course we will help you out to
learn
python a basics of a python we will help
you out
for a various machine learning how we
can how we can use those machine
learning or a deep learning algorithms
specifically
in your in your life science data maybe
your genomics data may be a
transcriptomic data
so this course is actually for you guys
and we will help you out we will
we will walk you through the entire
process of data science
in a life science so i would say this is
one of
the finest course in the world
which actually applying data science in
the life science
so we have uh sonalika we have another
question what is tensorflow for
so tensorflow is used for you know deep
learning
uh models i mean it's a framework
wherein you can you can write
deep learning code and you can you can
uh you know you can call various deep
learning models as well using pytorch
uh and uh from the tensorflow
anymore we have another question can i
graduate from this course with a
knowledge to work for data visualization
uh yes you will you will get lot of
insights lot of knowledge about data
visualization into this course
we will help you out let's see if you
have if you have given an input of a
gene expression data or a transcriptomic
data we will
we will help you how you can do data
visualization how we can generate data
data graphs how you can how you can
analyze those
biological data we will help you out
entire throughout this course
so while you share more questions uh let
me just take you throughout the
important resources
so first of all those who have not
registered yet and
they are looking forward to register
themselves uh you stand the last chance
today because
we have already started with the session
and this session was a free session for
everyone
uh that's why we didn't close the
registrations yet but we would be
closing them really very soon
so to register yourself you have to go
to the omixojic portal
and if you're signed up great if you're
not then please sign up and go to the
program page
now once you go to the program page you
will have a list of all the programs
which are ongoing and the upcoming ones
here you will get machine learning for
biomedical drug discovery and also
information biomedical drug discovery is
there as well
now i'm mentioning about this because uh
it's uh
the next part of this program which we
started the biomedical drug
data science and drug discovery program
and
once you go to the machine learning for
biomedical drug discovery program page
this program page would open up to
proceed
your application you have to request for
more
information and then register yourself
for the program here
fill out all the details we'll get your
registration and we'll reach
uh back to you you can also get all
these session details here
now everyone who has enrolled uh till
today
they all have been added to this program
page now when i say they have been added
to this program page it means
that throughout this course you need to
keep this program page with you you
uh you can simply bookmark it and
whenever we'll have a session you will
see the
zoom link for the session just uh below
this
and also the moment we are done with the
session i would be uploading the session
video and you and you can just see the
recorded session on the program
page itself and those who want to
register
themselves directly by paying so they
have to just
come to the options of payment we have
so we have three levels beginner
intermediate and and advanced now these
are the segregation
typically based on the provisions which
you would be having and the
provisions they
internet connection is unstable and
that's where uh
there is an issue so
this way you would have to proceed with
the payment
and those who have the promo code uh
they can just uh apply it here and like
what all topics would be covered in each
session this is the blog which we have
i'll be sharing this blog link with you
as well here it is in the chat box now
so you can simply go to this blog and
learn
what all programs are like what all
sessions we have
and what all topics would be covered in
each of the session
and what are the various other resources
for the session everything is mentioned
in the blog itself
and for today's recording i will be
sending out the recording to everyone
and it's also there
because we went live on youtube so we
have a question
the lip is asking python alone is good
enough for the drug discovery process or
r is mandatory uh
actually python is enough but r is
mostly used for a data visualization but
we have several packages as well in
python
for a data visualization so even if
somebody knows python basic knowledge
somebody have basic knowledge of python
that is actually enough for
it i hope that answers your question
deliv
uh so those who have enrolled i have
added them
already to the slacks page now this is
how
slack looks like many of you might be
here
who are new to slack so uh on your mail
id you would have the invitation for the
slack and you just need to accept the
invitation and join the group
and uh zahara you are asking uh that
how can you join the slack platform
you need to be uh you need to enroll
yourself you need to be one of our
participants and then we
send you out the link because uh the
groups which we have made on slack
they're just for the participants so
that we can communicate with them all
the session details
recordings and everything we i would be
sending out
the session meeting details and also the
recordings on slack after each session
so uh i think you have to be here it is
important
for you and also as elia told you that
we will be monitoring your uh progress
on the omix logic portal and also on the
server so we'll keep you updating here
in the group
as well who's performing best and
let's see who does great and
then we have the general group as well
where we keep on updating everything
about our upcoming programs now talking
about the
program which we have tomorrow that is
the chem informatics for biomedical drug
discovery
program we have the first session of
the program tomorrow and those people
who are enrolled in both the programs we
have kept the session
on alternate day so that they can be a
part of both the programs
so those are interested for chem
informatics for biomedical drug
discovery
they can register themselves on the
program page i'm
sending you the link of the same and
i had today send out a promo code you
can simply put it out here
uh by proceeding with your application
and also we would be closing the
registrations for chem informatics
program as well because
we would be starting tomorrow and if you
have any any doubts you can uh mail me
at
marketing at the ratefind.bio
and also you you can email us at
mummytablepine.com
if i'm not wrong you are a participant
for all the programs for all the four
phases and i've already added you so you
need to
check your mail id for the uh link of
this
for the slack channel and it would be
definitely there and you can
then be a part of the uh group if you
have any doubts you can ask sujisa
is here as well and if not then let's
meet
after tomorrow
hi sonalika um i just had a question um
just because i'm in the east coast i was
wondering what the
what the schedule so it's going to be
the class is going to be at this time
every
like on the schedule dates right yes
it would be uh as [ __ ] dude
uh so what time is the is it there for
you
for me yeah it works i just um you know
i just need to mark it off on my
calendar
um um it's eight it started for me at 8
30 a.m
est and that that worked for me we still
have a lot of things to do
sorry about this yeah
so um would how long is a session for
again was it i i didn't get the schedule
so
that's why i'm asking okay so the
session would be uh
uh one hour um like but it could go to
one or a few minutes as well because we
keep on having discussions people would
be asking questions
and uh i would be sending out google
calendar invites also to all our
participants
uh just after the session so you would
be having each and every session updated
on your calendar
and it would be easy for you to keep a
check in all the upcoming sessions
uh i think that would work for you
right and um my next question was like
so once we have the live sessions
we will be able to uh if you're expected
to go over the in asynchronous uh
sessions as well right the pre-recorded
lessons
um will we be uh able to access that
list like
okay so if we have like for the next
class the this is the pre-recorded
material that we need to watch
yes yes so here you have the
asynchronous material as well which you
can go through at your own pace
so uh the participants
they get the access to each and
everything they get the access to
all the courses and all the projects we
have sample projects as well
on our portal and i've given you the
access already
so you can go to the portal and take up
whatever course you want to so
as we are beginning with data science so
let's say you want to learn more before
other session let's say or want to
explode more
then you're most welcome you can just
start with the date with the
courses in the data science domain start
with our python or
learn whatever you want it's completely
up to you at your own pace
thank you welcome and also
let's say um bria starts with
our coding introduction to data science
and
uh once she completes the course
there are there are a number of
assignments in the course as well you
need to submit the assignments and
once you complete the course only then
you will get the certificate
and uh let me also tell you this that we
look forward
uh to updated profiles like i told you
that
uh we keep on communicating the progress
of each of the participant
across our different social platforms so
i want you all to please update your
profile with the profile picture
and also link all your social accounts
link your facebook link then
so that when we post about you across
people know who you are and what your
progress is
and it's a great way to um like stay
updated
with everything right because if you're
putting in so much er efforts
then uh why not um keep it on your
profile
as an achievement and you would get the
certificates once you complete the
course
okay then it was nice meeting you all uh
if you still have any doubts you can ask
or else you can mail
and also dr sujeeth uh you can
meet dr sujita as well
we have something okay okay thank you so
much for being a part of
yes sir over to you uh hi i have a
question
yes yes please answer um i'm trying to
access the t
server uh my my name is mohit i'm trying
to access the
d server bio account but i'm not
able to access invalid email or password
i've had the account
for yeah oh okay so are you using your
uh uh tba info server details which we
gave you
yeah you sent a password to my mail
right okay so uh
see uh we have actually made few changes
to our portal
we shifted uh from uh edo portal over
here that's where there were few
things that we were updating so now
now on the t by info server you can also
login with the login credentials you
used for the omixlogic portal
so that would work for you as well so
the id and the
password you use to login on the
omixlogic page
you can use that on the tbi info server
as well
you need not require any uh extra
credentials from
us and that should work for you but
still if if it does not then you can
text me over slack or mail me and i'll
just fix it for you
does it work yeah all right thanks uh i
am logging using my gmail account so i'm
not sure what to do now
i don't have any credentials for romix
logic uh you don't have any credentials
in you need not have any
credentials so when you sign up to omix
logic
you can do so with any of your id or
password you can also do so with
your linking your social so let's say
i just uh sign up and
you have to make your own id and
password or you can
directly link in let's say i link in my
google account with it
and uh minute connection is little bad
that's right it would be slow sorry
but yes so the moment you sign up my id
is pop up and you choose your
account it's completely up to you that's
what i want to say creating your id and
password
so you you can do one thing do you do
you have any other id
except this one i can do that but i lose
the progress
uh yeah that would be an issue that
would be an issue
if you don't mind can you share your
your credentials with me
uh just after this session i'll uh try
to
uh make it work for you sure thanks
okay please mail me at marketing and
today find out by
your credentials and i'll just look
forward to it and i'll just fix it
okay then everyone let's meet on uh
wednesday 16th of june we have second
session
i would be looking forward to meeting
meeting you all and
uh till then bye bye take care thank you
so much dr sujit
for uh the wonderful session you gave us
today
thank you sujit